[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin ihnen allen schönen guten
Abend in den nächsten 20 Minuten alles
Wichtige an diesem Montag und Christen
sportliches gehört natürlich dazu
Fußball Ski Alpin guten Abend dann
blicken wir jetzt auf die Themen
[Musik]
hier Freise mit schwerem Gepäck SPD-Chef
Klingbeil und der Fraktionsvorsitzende
Mütze nicht versprechen langfristige
Unterstützung stellen sich aber auch der
Kritik
Wahlkampf im krisenmodus Millionen
Türken kämpfen mit den Erdbeben folgen
die Opposition setzt auf einen
gemeinsamen Kandidaten gegen Präsident
Erdogan
und Kostenfaktor Fernweh die
Reisebranche lockt nach der
corona-pandemie wieder mit weltweiten
Zielen lässt sie sich aber teuer
bezahlen
[Musik]
heute überraschender Besuch der
SPD-Spitze in Kiew nach Kriegsausbruch
standen vor allem Sozialdemokraten im
Zentrum scharfer Kritik aus der Ukraine
weil so Kiew die SPD Putins Politik
jahrelang völlig falsch einschätzte und
mitteilt Milliarden schwere gas-deals
mit Moskau einzufädeln jetzt befindet
sich die Ukraine im Krieg wie grausam
und blutig zeigt sich ganz besonders an
der Front in bachmut wo der Bericht von
Christoph destruell beginnt
mittendrin im grauen von bachmut filmt
ein ukrainischer Soldat aus einem
Fenster heraus und legt Musik über den
Krieg
ein Clips Sieges Willen gerichtet an den
Rest der Welt und auch hier meldet man
werde sich nicht zurückziehen sondern
mit zusätzlichen truppenbachmut halten
doch gleichzeitig Berichten nicht wenige
Verteidiger der Stadt keine Artillerie
würde sie mehr absichern sie hätten fast
keine Munition mehr und ein
Überlebenschance unter 50%. sie
bräuchten jetzt Unterstützung es wird
das Wort des Tages auch knapp 700 km
weiter westlich in der Hauptstadt
Unterstützung sagt Bürgermeister
Klitschko auf die Frage was er sich von
seinem heutigen Besuch aus Deutschland
erhofft und meint damit wohl Waffen
möglichst viel möglichst schnell heikel
für die beiden SPD-Politiker ihr
maximales Entgegenkommen klingt so Rolf
Mütze nicht und ich sind jetzt hier um
mit vielen
Gesprächspartnern in der Ukraine zu
sprechen zu schauen wie weitere
Unterstützung aussehen kann und vor
allem um klar zu machen diese
Unterstützung die wir leisten die geht
uneingeschränkt weiter gerade für den
SPD-Fraktionschef ist die Reise nach
Kiew ein Balance sagt vorsichtig gesagt
ist der dort ziemlich unbeliebt hatte
immer wieder auf Diplomatie gesetzt und
Russland zu lange zu sehr vertraut
hätten andere auch verteidigt er sich
heute alle die die heute behaupten sie
haben alles gesehen
müssen das mit sich selbst ausmachen ich
kann für mich persönlich sagen dass ich
nicht alles gesehen habe dann ein
Treffen mit dem ukrainischen
Außenminister man spricht über die
Symbolik des Besuchs und Zuverlässigkeit
aber keine Überraschung besonderen Wert
legt die metropoleber auf
Artilleriemunition Munition in bachmut
fährt sie auf beiden Seiten und der Chef
der Söldnergruppe Wagner droht offen
nach Moskau dass er ohne Nachschub seine
Truppen zurückziehen wird einige spricht
dafür dass der Abnutzungskampf um
bachmut weitergeht
nach dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine will die Nato ihren Schutz für
die osteuropäischen Mitgliedstaaten
verstärken so zum Beispiel für Litauen
der baltische Staat hat eine Grenze zur
russischen Enklave Kaliningrad und zu
Belarus die Bundeswehr ist schon mit
Soldaten in Litauen und koordiniert den
NATO-Einsatz auch die Führung der
schnellen Eingreiftruppe hat Deutschland
übernommen aber bei der gibt's offenbar
neue Probleme mit den zugesagten Leopard
2 Panzern Nils Metzger und Thomas
Reichert
der Verteidigungsminister heute
Nachmittag auf dem Weg zum Truppenbesuch
in Litauen deutsche Soldaten üben dort
gemeinsam mit litauischen die Abwehr
eines russischen Angriffs für diesen
Fall hat Deutschland im Rahmen der NATO
noch viel mehr Unterstützung fest
versprochen Recherchen von ZDF frontal
aber zeigen die Bundeswehr bricht ihr
hilfe versprechen weil wieder Panzer
fehlen
wir brauchen die NATO wir wollen die
NATO wir wollen Teil der NATO sein aber
kommen unseren Verpflichtungen eben nur
begrenzt nach das offenbart sich jetzt
eben angesichts der weltpolitisch
dramatischen Lage es geht um das
Panzerbataillon 393 im thüringischen Bad
Frankenhausen das die modernsten Leopard
2 Panzer hat die A7V 30 dieser Panzer
müssten jederzeit bereitstehen für die
besonders schnelle Eingreiftruppe der
NATO zum Beispiel zur Verteidigung des
Baltikums am Abend des 8 Februar aber
erreicht eine alarmmail den zuständigen
panzergeneral von Buttler diese
vertrauliche verfügbarkeitsprognose
liegt im ZDF vor sie zeigt die 30
versprochenen Panzer kann das Bataillon
in diesem Jahr zu keinem Zeitpunkt auch
nur annähernd bereitstellen im Sommer
noch nicht mal die Hälfte der Grund ein
großer Teil der Panzer muss entweder
repariert oder gewartet werden
das würde zum einen natürlich heißen
dass Deutschland seinen Verpflichtungen
so wie sie eingegangen worden sind nicht
nachkommen kann die Bundeswehr erklärt
sie können weiterhin ihre
bündnisaufgaben ausnahmslos erfüllen der
Ausfall der versprochenen Panzer
gegenüber der NATO offenbar verheimlicht
aber weg Zweifel an der Zuverlässigkeit
der deutschen
wie sollen diese fehlenden Leopard
Panzer jetzt ersetzt werden die
ausführlichen Recherchen von ZDF frontal
können Sie nachlesen auf ZDF heute oder
jederzeit in unserer App
eine Bundesregierung drei Parteien und
viele Krisen Krisen die nicht unbedingt
helfen die Ziele im Koalitionsvertrag
schneller abzuarbeiten außerdem gab es
und gibt es unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen wie man Ziele erreicht
darum wollte die Ampel auf Schloss
Meseberg gestern und heute entsprechende
Disharmonien hinter sich lassen eisig so
schien es war die Stimmung in Meseberg
nur draußen Christiane hübscher
vielleicht ist das schon das
aufregendste Bild was in Meseberg
entstanden ist kurz sieht es so aus als
würde Olaf Scholz tatsächlich eine
Schneeballschlacht vom Zaun brechen und
überhaupt auf ihn zählt er da also ich
habe ein Schneeball geworfen aber wie
sich das für ein Bundeskanzler gehört
auf niemanden
danach setzt Tauwetter einen in
Brandenburg und wenn da vorher Eiszeit
war zwischen manchen in dieser Regierung
dann bemühen sich nach der Klausur alle
darum größtmögliche Geschlossenheit
rüberzubringen
es war eine gute Klausurtagung des
Bundeskabinetts und das hilft dann auch
für das politische Tagesgeschäft in den
nächsten Wochen in Berlin die
Zugewandtheit in dieser Konzentration
einer Kabinettsklausur hat glaube ich
allen noch mal deutlich gemacht was es
für ein Privileg ist in der
Bundesregierung zu sein wie sehr wir
aufeinander angewiesen sind ein
fühlbares unterhaken will Olaf Scholz
bemerkt haben an Tag 2 der Klausur ging
es vor allem um die nächsten großen
Transformationen Digitalisierung und
Energiewende diese Zuversicht dass die
dass es möglich ist dass es in 10 20 30
Jahren für ein Land wie Deutschland
weiterhin gilt dass wir vorne dabei sind
in der Weltwirtschaft dass wir unsere
Kraft erhalten können das ist auch das
worüber wir geredet haben Beschlüsse
aber gibt es nicht
dass mehr nicht kritisiert die
Opposition es klingt danach ist er bis
in Meseberg überhaupt keine Einigung
gegeben überhaupt keine Fortschritte was
wir gehört haben ist heiß die Luft
zentrale Reformprojekte des eigenen
Koalitionsvertrages wie zum Beispiel die
Kinder Grundsicherung oder auch die
Verkehrswende werden nicht umgesetzt
oder blockiert atmosphärisch mag diese
Klausur was gebracht haben ob sie auch
realpolitisch hilft muss ich noch zeigen
da wollen wir doch noch mal nachhören
bei Shake unterlab energy in
berlin-chakunta wie ist dein Eindruck
was hat die Klausur unterm Strich
gebracht diese Klausuren in Meseberg die
sind immer auch eine Möglichkeit für
Teambuilding wenn es mal rappelt und
diesmal hatte man schon sehr den
Eindruck dass da auch viel
Selbstvergewisserung einer
durchgerüttelten Koalition im Spiel
gewesen ist in den vergangenen Wochen
und Monaten hatte Olaf Scholz Kabinett
ja vor allem durch Sticheleien und
profilierungsgesten von sich reden
gemacht und da wollte man offensichtlich
heute
dagegenhalten und hat das gemacht indem
man noch mal die Überschrift über dieser
Koalition ordentlich abgestaubt hat man
ist mal als fortschrittskoalition
gestartet dieses Wort ist jetzt im
Rahmen dieser Klausur wieder sehr oft
gefallen und wurde wieder so ein
bisschen beschworen und es wirkte so als
ob sich alle noch einmal darauf
verständigt hatten das ist besser ist
sich auf das eigene Projekt zu
konzentrieren und dann den Umfragen
nicht abzustürzen die Frage ist
allerdings wie lange das hält denn auch
wenn man sich heute noch mal über Themen
vergewissert hat und auch wenn Olaf
Scholz gesagt hat wir brauchen mehr
Fortschritt Tempo und Zuversicht gilt es
dann eben bei den nächsten großen
Projekten zum Beispiel bei klima-fragen
oder Verkehrsfragen sich dann zu einigen
und da steht dann jetzt nun der Appell
im Raum etwas harmonischer voranzugehen
als es in den letzten Monaten der Fall
war Chako und ala vielen Dank nach
Berlin gibt also jedenfalls noch viel zu
tun für die Bundesregierung und so sieht
das auch die nationale
Wissenschaftsakademie Leopoldina und
fordert von der amperegierung mehr Tempo
und Ehrgeiz um noch die Ziele des
Pariser klimaschutzabkommens erreichen
zu können in einem entsprechenden
Diskussionspapier empfehlen die
Wissenschaftler etwa den Ausbau des
europäischen Emissionshandels und der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft
vor genau einem Monat ereignete sich die
gewaltige Erdbebenkatastrophe in der
Türkei mehr als 46.000 tote zählt das
Land bisher ganze Städte sind
unbewohnbar und 14 Millionen Menschen
und damit etwa ein Sechstel der
Bevölkerung des Landes leidet unter den
Folgen
Präsident Erdogan steht in der Kritik
zur Wahl Mitte Mai haben sich sechs
Oppositionsparteien gegen ihn
zusammengeschlossen und schicken jetzt
doch einen gemeinsamen Kandidaten ins
Rennen mehr von Jörg Brase
er wird Präsident Erdogan herausfordern
Kemal Kilic darulu wird Spitzenkandidat
eine sechs Parteien Bündnisses
unser Bündnis steht für Frieden und für
Brüderlichkeit unser großes Ziel ist es
der Türkei Wohlstand und Wachstum zu
bringen
weil kilica Rudow beim Wahl Volk nicht
so populär ist wie andere CHP Politiker
hatte Meral seine Kandidatur bislang
abgelehnt die Chefin der zweitgrößten
Oppositionspartei hatte das Bündnis am
vergangenen Freitag aus Protest platzen
lassen heute aber sah sie plötzlich
wieder mit am Tisch für Beobachter nutzt
dieses Hin und Her vor allem dem
amtsinnhaber
wird sagen wenn die Opposition jetzt
schon in der Krise ist welche Krisen
werden wir dann nach der Wahl erleben
wir wollen die ein Land regieren Erdogan
wird sagen dann wählt lieber Stabilität
Welt mich
die Chancen der Opposition Präsident
Erdogan abzulösen waren bisher nicht
schlecht knapp zwei Drittel der
Bevölkerung sind unzufrieden mit der
Arbeit der Regierung nach dem
verheerenden Erdbeben daraufhin waren
deren Umfragewerte eingebrochen bei
einigen Forschungsinstituten lag die
Opposition teilweise klar vorn der
jüngste Streit im Oppositionslager kam
Präsident Erdogan der ganz gelegen
ein iranisches Sprichwort sagt sie
setzten sich an einen Tisch redeten und
trennten sich wieder und genauso ist es
gekommen während wir uns um das Wohl der
Menschen kümmern geht es ihnen nur um
die Macht
nun also steht Erdogans gegen Kandidat
fest kann das Rennen um das höchste
Staatsamt der Türkei Beginn
t jetzt zu den Parlamentswahlen in
Island da ist Premierministerin Callas
bestätigt worden sie konnte mit ihrem
Kurs die Ukraine militärisch zu
unterstützen im Wahlkampf Punkten Callas
wollte mit ihrer wirtschaftsliberalen
Partei
31,2% der Stimmen und verbesserte ihr
Ergebnis von 2019 um regieren zu können
muss sie sich aber wieder
Koalitionspartner suchen
die Justiz in Belarus hat gleich mehrere
Oppositionelle zu langen Haftstrafen
verurteilt auch die prominente
Anführerin der Opposition Svetlana
tiranowskaja sie wurde in Abwesenheit zu
15 Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt unter
anderem wegen Landesverrats die
ranowskaja lebt in Litauen im Exil
zurück nach Deutschland hier bleibt die
Zahl der Jugendlichen ohne
Schulabschluss weiter hoch sie sei
erschreckend so eine Studie im Auftrag
der Bertelsmann Stiftung demnach
beendeten 2021 rund
47.500 junge Menschen ihre Schulzeit
ohne Abschluss das entspricht etwa jedem
16 Schüler laut Auswertung sind
Jugendliche mit ausländischer
Staatsbürgerschaft fast dreimal so oft
betroffen wie deutsche und Jungen
öfter als Mädchen
problematisch ist aktuell auch die
Situation bei den Pflegediensten in
einer Branchenumfrage haben fast 70%
angegeben sie sehen ihre wirtschaftliche
Existenz bedroht Grund sein gestiegene
Kosten praktisch allen Bereichen und der
Personalmangel keine guten Aussichten
also für Pflegebedürftige und ihre
Angehörigen
wer zu Hause ein Pflegefall zu versorgen
hat kennt es aus eigener Erfahrung es
ist unglaublich schwer überhaupt einen
Pflegedienst zu finden
91% der ambulanten Dienste mussten im
letzten halben Jahr Neukunden ablehnen
manche haben schon Insolvenz angemeldet
wenn die Unternehmen weiter in dieser
schwierigen prekären Lage bleiben dass
sie schließen erste Schließungen haben
wir schon das haben langen Ende die
Versorgung in Deutschland dann komplett
in Frage gestellt wird
steigende Kosten und fehlende Personal
auch in den Heimen macht sich dies
finanziell bemerkbar einige Stationen
mussten bereits schließen ein
Teufelskreis denn wenn weniger Menschen
gepflegt werden sinken natürlich auch
die Einnahmen der Häuser
wir leben momentan in der Branche eine
Strukturveränderung wo viele Dinge zu
einem toxischen Gemisch zusammengeführt
werden das sind in der erste Linie neue
gesetzliche Regelungen dazu kommt der
Fachkräftemangel der uns hart zusetzt um
sicherlich die allgemeine
Preissteigerung im Bereich Energie und
Sachkosten
300.000 weitere Pflegekräfte werden in
den nächsten Jahren benötigt allein mit
ausländischen Personal wird diese Lücke
nicht zu schließen sein deshalb fordern
alle Experten einen gemeinsamen
pflegegipfel damit der Pflegesektor
nicht zusammenbricht
jetzt zum Geschäft das von Sehnsucht und
Fernweh lebt und auch auf der heute
beginnenden Tourismusmesse ITB bitte
bedient wird lange und heftig hat die
Branche während Corona ja leiden müssen
aber jetzt sind die Veranstalter
ziemlich optimistisch dass 2023 ein ja
wie früher werden könnte die
Buchungszahlen Stimmen jedenfalls auch
wenn Urlaub wie so vieles andere auch
teurer geworden ist Nils Schneider
die Deutschen sind wieder im Reisefieber
in diesem Jahr haben sie schon doppelt
so viel für Urlaub ausgegeben wie im
gesamten letzten Jahr fast 59 Milliarden
Euro so der Reiseverband es könnte ein
neues Rekordjahr für die
Tourismuswirtschaft werden die Favoriten
der Deutschen sind eigentlich wieder die
die es in der vor coronazeit auch waren
alles rund ums Mittelmeer
besonders auffällig ist dass das
östliche Mittelmeer im Moment besser
läuft als der westliche Teil die Türkei
ist Platz 1 bei den sommerbuchungen
trotz Erdbebenkatastrophe aber meist
billiger als Spanien oder Italien
allgemein spüren die Menschen die
gestiegenen Preise
ich habe schon gebucht es ist 50 Prozent
teuer also letztes Jahr also das habe
ich auch darüber gebucht das ist 50%
teurer einfach so
kurz weg drei vier bis fünf oder sechs
Tage und mache vor allen Dingen im
Inland Urlaub Italien tatsächlich gerade
im Winter in Berlin ist alles wonach man
sich sehend Wärme gutes Essen Gründe für
höhere Kosten sind die weltweite
Inflation und gestiegene Energiepreise
urlaub in Deutschland ist relativ teuer
es gibt aber auch Sparmöglichkeiten aber
wenn man so ein bisschen weggeht aus den
großen ballungs touristischen
Ballungsgebieten also weiß ich jetzt
Oberbayern Schwarzwald
Nord und Ostsee da gibt es Möglichkeiten
ansonsten sind Pauschalreisen wieder der
Renner und all inclusive Urlaube da
sieht man genau welche Kosten auf einen
zukommen
so hier geht's jetzt weiter mit der
Fußball-Bundesliga und da läuft bei der
Eintracht aus Frankfurt nicht so richtig
gut Christian
schlapp noch ist aber alles möglich in
der Champions League und auch im Pokal
doch mit Blick auf die eher markere
bilanzin der Bundesliga Rückrunde mit
bisher zwei Siegen in sechs Spielen
stimmt auch das 2:22 in Wolfsburg nicht
gerade euphorisch
Kevin Trapp sorgt zunächst dafür dass
das Eintracht Tor nicht zu hoch ist der
Pfosten muss in die Verankerung er hatte
ein paar Zentimeter herausgerückt die
Wolfsburger Führung nach 10 Minuten
hätte omamamo stand allerdings auch in
einem Eishockey Tor untergebracht
die Gäste stecken den Rückstand locker
weg Randal columani mit dem Kopf und
Evan enika sehenswert mit links drehen
das Spiel innerhalb von vier Minuten
Mitte der ersten Halbzeit
Jannik Gerhardt erzählt für die
Wolfsburger dann kurz vor der Pause das
zwei zu zwei das ist auch schon der
entstand ein Unentschieden dass keinem
Team wirklich was bringt
ja und alles zum 23 Spieltag so auch das
4:1 von Leverkusen gegen Hertha gestern
auch online heute.de und in der heute
App er sind das Erfolgserlebnis für
andreas Sander gute eine Woche vor
Beginn des alpinen Weltcup Finals beim
Super G in Espen USA belegte er Rang
zwei und wollte sich über den ersten
Podestplatz seiner langen Karriere im
Weltcup
15 Jahre musste der 33-Jährige
Nordrhein-Westfalen auf diesen
Augenblick warten in seinem 180
Weltcuprennen fuhr oder besser raste
andreas Sander auf den zweiten Platz und
damit aufs Podium vom startwerk stellte
er immer neue Bestzeiten auf 300 waren
es noch bei der letzten Zeitnahme vor
dem Ziel wo ihn dann nur hauchte eine
500 Sekunden vom Sieg trennten durchaus
nicht fehlerfrei gewann der Schweizer
Marco Odermatt seinen fünften Super G in
dieser Saison andreas Sander noch vor
dem starken Norweger Alexander Armut
Kilde wird diesen super-gnespen als
einen der Höhepunkte seiner Karriere in
Erinnerung halten
ja er sei mega happy was wir natürlich
vielen Dank Christine winterliche
Aussichten die gibt's gleich von Katja
vorne
SPD-Chef Lars klingball im heute journal
Interview mit Christian Sievers ab
zweiundzwanzig Uhr so viel von uns danke
und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend der Schnee der da heute von
West nach Ost über uns hinweggezogen ist
hier rosa eingefärbt dürfte sie
eigentlich nicht überrascht haben blau
hier das sind die Regenfälle und nach
dem Schneefällen lockerten die Wolken in
Norddeutschland ganz schön auf und der
Nacht ziehen neue Regen und Schneefelder
von der Nordseeküste weiter in Richtung
Lausitz und dann reicht es natürlich
wieder für Glätte auf Straßen und
Gehwegen im Osten Deutschlands aber auch
in den Mittelgebirgen der Wind kommt aus
südlichen Richtung und die Temperaturen
sinken am Alpenrand und hier im Osten
bis -3 Grad deutlich milder bleibt die
Nacht am Niederrhein mit plus 4 Grad und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen im
Norden so zwischen ein und 7 Grad im
Süden sind es drei bis zehn Grad und
auch morgen fallen wieder Schnee und
Regen besonders in diesem Streifen
ungefähr von der Eifel bis zum Spreewald
über Norddeutschland sieht ein richtiges
Sturmtief es gibt
orkanartige Sturmböen direkt an der See
und Winter Gewitter in
Schleswig-Holstein sonst gibt's häufig
Schneefall aber zwischen der Donau und
dem Oberrhein sehen sie häufiger mal die
Sonne am Mittwoch und am Donnerstag ist
es im Nordosten kühl aber freundlich und
in Süddeutschland droht dauert Regen
guten Abend